the jurgen experience has anybody ever
come to you and said hey
our community is kind of screwed up we
don't have a good food source here
would you help us establish something
like this
yeah i've been uh have you designed
these things for folks
not i mean not for a whole community
like this uh
it sounds like that'll be a great thing
though yeah especially now when we're
realizing that it's difficult
when the food supply chain goes down or
something goes wrong and it's difficult
to get food to people
wouldn't it be great to have i've always
said this that it would be great if you
had like
the neighborhood had like one large plot
of land
and everyone in the neighborhood lived
off that plot of land
sure that like have a little mini
central park in every neighborhood
right right um you're talking my
language i mean uh
the idea of of uh well i mean you're
familiar with urban agriculture
i mean we have food deserts right food
deserts is a big big problem but a lot
of times food deserts are in pretty run
down parts of
the city that have vacant lots and
um uh there's there's a lot of
productive capacity in these places i
was
one of the interesting ones i was on was
in st louis
and these three young couples had come
together and they had
they had purchased an old it was an old
crack house that the city bulldozed
so there's this vacant lot it was you
know half an acre it wasn't very big
um half an acre and these three couples
uh they got apartments
nearby like within you know two minutes
walk and it was in a pretty run down
area
of the city a rundown neighborhood and
they just started farming
in this in this half acre
and told all the neighbors bring us your
food scraps they got some chickens
they started making compost they put up
a little greenhouse they put up a
kitchen
and very very simple poor boy bootstrap
you know nothing and they
quickly became a whole community
whatever
place for kids to come
because kids were mesmerized by the
chickens
they had a worm bed the plants growing
they cooked stuff and i was there
you know i was there with them for a
couple of hours and here come here
here come kids down the sidewalk you
know pulling a little red wagon with
food scraps in it and and they're
feeding the worm beds and
it's it's fantastic they were feeding
like you know 30 families
out of this old crack house foundation
that's amazing and it was just wonderful
and they were doing it
as a as a gift to the inner city you
know as a as a gift uh to the
inner city but i asked them i said so so
how much of st
louis's food could be produced this way
they said if you take out the dairy
and the beef you know the big the big
mega stuff st louis
could feed its entire city within the
city limits this way
wow and that's true in detroit it's true
in baltimore it might not be true in l.a
but the the but but here's the thing
we don't have to solve every single
person's problem
to start solving some and and our
problem is so many times
i start down this path and somebody
starts throwing at me the most extreme
situation
and you know what i don't have all the
answers for the most extreme situation
you know the
the single mom of four minority in a
food desert in
whatever okay i don't have the answer to
every single situation
but i'm looking at suburbia i'm looking
at at incredible things that people
are doing and opportunities and if we
just did what we
know um i mean i ran into a lady in um
in in edmonton uh british
alberta yeah thank you and she was 50
single lady living in a fifth floor
condominium just wanted to wanted to
farm in a worst way she had no money
no land nothing and
she just had this epiphany one day she
said i know i have one friend that has a
backyard
she went to this friend of the backyard
she said um would you mind if i grew up
like a 10 foot by 10 foot garden in your
back i just want to grow something
friend said sure sure
so she gave her little 10 10 by 10 plot
group started a garden
well the lady's neighbor saw the garden
and she said do you think your friend
would put a garden in my backyard
and they said well i'll ask well sure
i met this lady 18 months after this
initial
conversation with her friend she was
farming
18 backyards had a part-time employee
was a full-time farmer
her all of her tools were on the side of
her bicycle she bicycled from spot to
spot to spot with all of her tools
and her she started a business called on
borrowed ground
and growing food so the thing is
is there creativity is there opportunity
oh
it's up the wazoo if we would become as
interested in this as we are the latest
dysfunction in the kardashians
or or you know you know what i'm saying
the latest whatever
yeah and it's not that we don't have
time for it not that we don't have money
for it
if if there's one really positive thing
to come out of this pandemic
i hope that it's a restructuring
of what's valuable in life and if we can
if we can even grab a 30
bump in that value trajectory
it will have been the best thing that
ever happened to that's a large bump